welcome back to gamespot news where i
decided to wear the glasses that no one
likes
i read the comments multiverses season 1
finally got a release date a ton of new
announcements from thq nordic and sonic
frontiers is absolutely definitely
positively not getting delayed
[Music]
what began as an indefinite delay has
turned into a short one-week wait as a
multiverse's season one has been
confirmed for an august 15th start date
while also confirming that the first new
character of the season morty smith from
rick and morty will debut 8 days later
on august 23rd his grandpa rick sanchez
will also join the roster during the
game's inaugural season no release date
has been announced for rick's edition
the developers also shared a snapshot of
what the first season of multiverses
will be adding to the game including
online ranked lobbies a single player
arcade mode and more characters beyond
the already confirmed rick and morty
just waiting on that larry david
announcement now thq nordic had a
massive showcase today including new
game announcements the rumors were true
a new alone in the dark is coming
returning the series all the way back to
its 1992 roots to revisit key elements
of a game that helped give birth to the
survival horror genre it features a lot
of elements from the 1992 title
including its setting de setto manor and
its two main playable characters private
detective edward conby and emily
hartwood amnesia the dark descent and
soma writer mikhail hedberg will be
penning the game's script who says that
the story will be more active than the
original expect cinematic cutscenes and
voice dialogue in addition to notes
letters and other items you'll find as
you explore deseto mana and the rest of
the world recreation is coming from
three fields entertainment a studio made
up of developers from electronic arts
and criterion games including folks who
previously worked on the burnout and
need for speed series and it's clear the
wreck side of the game draws inspiration
from those beloved racing titles stunts
crashes and takedowns are a big part of
the events you'll compete in and it
sounds like just about everything in the
game will provide you opportunities for
those competitions instead of covering a
city recreation takes place in its own
drivable state made up of four different
counties that you can explore to
discover shortcuts challenges and
breakable billboards there are 400
square kilometers of area in the game
and you can drive on all of it according
to three fields for more information on
all the announcements made during
today's presentation head to
gamespot.com in a business briefing that
was recently held sega senior executive
vp koichi fukuzawa and executive vp
makoto takahashi explained that the
company had no plans to delay the open
world sonic frontiers and is still on
track to release this year despite the
mixed reception it has received from
critics and fans since it was officially
revealed quote we do not consider
postponing the launch at this point
sega's official translation of the
response reads with the communication
with users we intend to reflect the
parts that can be reflected within the
development timeline and to build
empathy with users sonic team head
takashi izuka had previously said that
he wasn't surprised by the feedback and
that once players get their hands on
sonic frontiers they'll understand what
makes it feel unique when compared to
other sonic games this resolute stance
comes amid a sea of recent delays
including marvel's midnight suns
forespoken and hogwarts legacy which
just got delayed today to february of
2023 i don't know the last time a sonic
project got delayed to address feedback
it ended up working out very nicely for
the blue blur hopefully sega's
confidence in frontiers is justified
when players go hands-on with it later
this year
alright everyone that is it for today's
gamespot news and this week's gamespot
news devante will be your host next week
let us know if you are at all worried
about sonic frontiers or if you plan to
jump into any of those thq nordic games
and we'll see you here on monday
[Music]